this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show the ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
christy wright ramsey personality and
number one best-selling author of the
book
business boutique is my co-host today as
we take your questions about life
and about money it is a free call at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you jump in
and we will talk rachel is going to
start off this hour she's in washington
d.c
hi rachel how are you i'm good dave how
are you
better than i deserve what's up
so my question is i have a rental home
it used to be
my uh home and then i
moved out when my husband passed away
about uh almost five years ago
and so it's been uh it's been about
three years
i've been renting it so now i'm at a
point where i'm trying to decide do i
get rid of it or do i do i still keep it
i owe about
uh 338 on it it was about 525.
[Music]
and where are you living i i bought
another home
you bought another home okay all right i
did yeah
and how's your career going
well right now i um in october of 2019
or so
um i started a business uh at
tax and accounting for small businesses
a type of business not not doing too too
well right now
kind of maybe deciding to jump back into
the workforce
okay so that little bit of pinch
uh on the income side makes you look at
this rental
yes yeah so he's gonna change why
because
after all the smoke clears with the
occasional vacancy and the occasional
repair
you're not making a ton on this thing
not really
i mean it's covering the uh the mortgage
and
just a little bit over that and that's
about it yeah there's not not much
wiggle room in this deal
so um it just sounds like there's not a
lot of reasons to keep it
yeah i mean i was kind of holding on to
it for thinking about but you know
yeah the home that we shared with my
husband but yeah at this point i'm at a
crossroads a little bit
well i understand and you know part of
that
uh holding on to it went away when you
rented it right
yeah i mean that that's like you know
you're moving it from
the home where we did life to now a
business transaction
but that gave you a little further time
to put some distance between you and his
passing
a little bit more healing right right
yeah
yeah yeah i mean emotionally letting go
of it today is different than it would
have been four years ago
yeah at the time i wasn't ready yeah i
definitely wasn't ready yeah
so christy i wonder how her business
would be affected if she didn't have
this strain
yeah i'm just thinking about just the
progression even as as you're describing
this rachel from like you're saying five
years ago and then now because even if
you do sell it now
it doesn't mean it's gonna be easy it's
still you're still gonna have that
emotional pull
it'll be easier than it was five years
ago but it's still not gonna be easy but
i just wonder
what could be freed up if you did let it
go
what could be freed up in your emotions
in the headache of having to deal with
it i mean
having a rental is not just free money
coming in like that that's work on your
part it's maintenance it's the
dealing with the day day-to-day of it
and so um i
i think that while it might be difficult
to walk through that
to sell it what would be on the other
side would be worth it
i mean you have a couple hundred
thousand dollars in your pocket i'm just
wondering if your business might
if you took a little strain off of you
and just leaned into that business if
you can make that business turn the
corner
rather than head back into the workforce
uh sometimes
stress and the the weight of several
things on you keep you from focusing on
the business and
i think there might be a release there
so i'm definitely selling it
um i have no reasons on my list over
talking to you to keep it
uh you're gonna be free uh i mean the
there'll be some sadness but but it
doesn't make you any money
uh it's it's really at the end of the
day from a financial standpoint it's
really not a blessing at this point
and the uh having the actual money in
the bank out of that equity would be
and i'll give you some options and stay
on the line rachel because i would love
to send you
my book business boutique there's i
cover a lot of different aspects of
business in this book it's your plan to
win but it also
might help you identify what's not
working is it your pricing is it your
customers is it your marketing what
hasn't been working in your small
business that you could like dave said
improve fix iterate to be able to make
that thing work
in this new season so stay on the line
and kelly can send that to you
absolutely yeah all right noah's with us
in
fort worth texas hi noah how are you
good how are you dude
better than i deserve how can we help
great so i am having a hard time
trying to decide between saving up for a
down payment on a house
or investing i really want to start
investing more
into my retirement income okay
you can do that so uh great so i
am 23 years old i just finished baby
step three
um you know i really
i want to start investing more into my
retirement just because i see
the potential outcome of that and i
really don't have house fever right now
but
i also want to have enough for a down
payment and
hopefully i guess if i ever wanted to
get what are you making
i make 70 dollars good for you at 23.
what are you doing
uh business intelligence very good yeah
and that's going to go nowhere but up
from there
where are you living now right i'm
living at home right now
but i got an apartment i'm moving into
you next month okay that's a good plan
i think that's a really good first step
and if you're putting 15 percent of your
income away and baby step four into
retirement can you not save towards the
house above that
no yeah i can and that was my original
plan but i didn't know if i should be
sitting because it's like almost
an extra six thousand dollars yeah i
could be saving for a house but
you know well i mean and you know three
years from now you'd have 18 000 you'd
be 26 years old that's not the end of
the world right
or at any point you want to dial back
baby step four and we'll do what we call
baby step three b which is a reduced or
temporarily put on hold baby step four
while you save
aggressively for a down payment more
aggressively uh that'll be fine
but um you're making good money and
here's the thing uh three years from
today you're not gonna be making 70 000
in business intelligence
that's exactly what i was going to say i
was like you're going to be making more
so you're already going to make
that goal faster yeah i i think you can
put 15 away and still have a house in
two to three years
and i think that's a fine plan there's
nothing wrong with that at all
awesome thank you i really appreciate
the help hey thanks for the call we
appreciate you joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so chrissy when
you're running a business or your own
budget
uh projections are good uh looking out
in the future and projecting your
numbers
are are good uh the first thing we tend
to do is we tend to just take what we
know today
and extend that yeah linearly assuming
it's gonna be the exact same thing
you know like in his case he's going to
make 70 000 for the next three years and
you and i are looking at each other
going
23 is making 70 already right business
intelligence is a hot topic
a lot of stuff happening with data right
now it's one of the hottest you know
career fields you could possibly get
into in the tech world right and
uh and if he's good at it and leans in
which he apparently is because he's
already landing stuff
then he you know it's very possible
folks that he doubles his income in
three years right
right and so you don't take your
business income or your personal
income and necessarily project it
on a line like i'm making whatever i'm
making now i'm always going to make that
it's
very seldom you do that now some jobs
you're in you get cost living raising
that's it but other positions you're in
wow you can really be on a curve the
same thing's true with your business
with a product line
or anything else that's right this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
so
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
well this week is national financial
literacy month not this week this month
is
and we always celebrate that by
celebrating teachers
because christie you and i both know
that teachers make the world go around
the good ones
yes the ones that don't mail it in yes
we can all look back in our past and go
that teacher influenced me in that area
that teacher
i mean i can name five or six off the
top of my head that had a big impact uh
some of the others i don't even remember
their name yep that's right but uh but
they're all that coaches
teachers these kinds of people come
across your life they they're life
changers yeah
the good ones and so we want to honor
the teachers we think you're awesome in
the past year you've pivoted you've
prepared for all scenarios
try to say stay safe and still love your
kids and teach your kids
and make an impact on your kids on the
students and that's why we're
celebrating educators with our teacher
appreciation giveaway
it's sponsored by mint mobile the
affordable premium
wireless provider because of the hard
work and dedication of teachers our
foundations in personal finance
curriculum has now been taught in more
than 48 percent of the high schools
in america and impacted the lives of
over 5
million students to say thanks for
inviting teachers to enter our teacher
appreciation giveaway
we're giving away amazing prizes like
for instance the grand prize
five thousand dollars cash there's no
purchase necessary you just gotta sign
up to uh
be registered then no need to sign up
more than once because that puts you in
the hat put your name in the hat and
we're going to do a drawing among you
amazing teachers you go to
ramseysolutions.com
teacher to enter the giveaway ends
april the 30th speaking of amazing
teachers
we have amy burns from centerberg ohio
zinderberg high school
who is a teacher of our high school
curriculum the foundations in
personal finance hey amy how are you i
am fantastic
thank you and yourself well just the
same i'm honored to speak with you
and i'm honored to be with you so you've
been teaching
uh for how many years overall this is my
eighth year teaching i'm a second career
teacher
wow good for you thank you and so and
you've been teaching the finance
curriculum the personal finance
personal foundations and personal
finance curriculum i can't say it
uh for how long for about five years now
oh so most of the time you've been
teaching then
absolutely yeah very cool so what's the
kids reaction to this
they are so excited and mostly because
they
most of our students recognize you in
your face
from their their parents going through
financial peace university
oh okay well that can be good and that
can be bad
depending depending
[Music]
tell me about the cli tell me about the
class when the students are asking
questions
what is the what's the initial response
or what's the
the quest the type of questions that
they have when they first are getting it
you know
introduced to this curriculum you know
it just runs the gamut they're just
they're all over the board it depends on
what year it is what you know
what time of the semester it is but
mostly
those students are wanting to know like
what's one thing that they can cut out
of their budget that wouldn't make a
huge change in their daily life
another one would be um you know i still
have some
moments in their life that they can be
very impulsive
and what are some tips that they can get
out of you know
get out of that habit yeah yeah that's
that's powerful
i'm curious amy so i spoke to teenagers
when i first started at this company
and one of the things i struggled with
and talking to teenagers was that
some of them many of them didn't really
have an interest because money seemed
like this far off topic
you know it seemed like that thing i'll
have to deal with later and they had the
bank of mom and dad a 24-hour atm so
they didn't really have an incentive to
live on a budget
how do you help them get motivated
excited
you know about learning this right now
before they make all those mistakes
well i have to say that i am very
privileged to
to work in a school district where
we don't see that a lot oh wow we have
very self-sufficient
students here with families that
encourage them to
earn their way and so i i
get a very different um atmosphere here
but as far as that goes
my freshmen don't usually get the whole
financial personal finance idea
because they haven't had jobs yet
they're still coming out of middle
school
but once the kids get in to be
sophomores
and juniors and especially seniors
they're starting to get jobs
they're starting to look at getting a
car etc etc
so um those things
are the kids that are sophomores juniors
and seniors they have a better grasp
that makes sense of what personal
finance
is and the importance of they're working
yeah yeah exactly
so in the five years you've been
teaching this what are your class sizes
and
and how many people have gone through it
well i'd like you to remember that we
have um
less than 350 students in our school oh
in the whole school
in the whole school we're very small
we're rural school here in ohio
and i have had anywhere from about 15
to a full class of 25. wow
that's a lot and within the next two
years i hear a rumor coming down the
pike that
ohio will start requiring
personal financial management as a
graduation requirement
wow i hope so that's awesome i hope so
too our guys in the uh our education
department are involved in the lobbying
in a bunch of states
a lot of states have made it mandatory
and we get in there and talk to the
legislatures as often as we can
to let them know that yeah this is what
the kids need
because all of us that are adults you
know we look back and we go why didn't
they teach us this in school
you know we say that also in the same
routine and yet there's teachers like
amy and 48
of the high schools that are doing this
so
very cool thank you so much you're
obviously a rock star we appreciate you
teaching this and
well thank you we appreciate you taking
a second to talk to us about it we're so
so proud to be associated with you and
i'm proud to have you out there so thank
you thank you thank you for being one of
those superstar teachers that doesn't
mail it in that that really does change
lives
so you know when you're teaching
something and you and i
have the same experience as teachers
we're teachers
uh in a different vein in a sense but
when we get somebody back five years
later that's exactly right
and they say man i went to that seminar
and it changed my life that's right
the information yeah changed my life
sometimes i say you changed my life
which is not true i didn't
or you didn't but what we were teaching
them when they applied it
did right and that's what amy's doing
and so you i can't imagine being a high
school teacher that has a
25 year old comeback right what six
seven eight years later
and said you know when you taught that
you set me up to win with my new spouse
and my new kid and yeah
wow it's really interesting too because
i feel like especially in high school
you could apply this to any time in life
but especially high school
a lot of times those students that come
in as freshmen and they leave as seniors
they're older and they're taller but
they're not acting all that different
and the teacher it would be easy to feel
like oh i didn't make a difference in
their life because i didn't see this
huge transformation in these four years
but the seeds that are planted it's
amazing how that continues to grow and
they come back at 25
and you hear these success stories and i
can think of gosh all the people that
poured into me in high school from
teachers to coaches my young life leader
seeds they planted that now
are coming to fruition you're seeing the
fruit of that but of course when i left
as a senior they probably didn't feel
like oh my gosh you know i see a huge
change in
in christy brown you know at the time
and so i just i i hope that's an
encouragement to teachers coaches those
people that are
teaching these classes even if you don't
see a huge transformation
in your class or in those four years the
seeds you're planting
are going to produce fruit later and it
matters
you were a young life leader and you
experienced the exact same thing from
the leader perspective
rachel cruz who was young life leader
daniel ramsey my son was a young life
leader and so
again working that's working ministry
with teens but um
but i mean you can get some kid who's
just stuck on stupid
yeah i mean they're just stuck on stupid
and yet they're still hearing you
yeah and all of a sudden it dislodges
the stupid dislodges at some point and
they turn a corner
and you're you may not be around when
that happens right but
you still planted the seeds in there
that caused it to happen that's right
just uh
just actually this week i was doing a
facebook and instagram live walking
through my devotional and i
held up my bible i don't think i've ever
shown it on you know on camera and i
said this is the bible that a friend
gave me in high school and it was a
friend that saw something in me
that i didn't see in myself and i don't
even know was present at the time but he
saw something in me and i still treasure
that bible to this day just thinking of
how far that bible has brought me you
didn't see it when i was a sophomore or
even a senior
but you begin to see it over time and
sometimes we get those success stories
and sometimes we don't
but it's just a good reminder that uh
that those seeds
continue to grow yeah oh by the way the
devotional
is called living true 40 days to get
back to you
and you're going through it again on
instagram right now right yeah leading
people through it in these 40 days
after easter when jesus would have
appeared to people in the earth it's
been a fun journey so far get your copy
at christywright.comdevotional or at
ramseysolutions.com
and if they want to follow you it's at
christy wright christina
christiebright on instagram
on instagram be sure you jump in there
if you want to join her on the
devotional process
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we talk about your life and your
money it's a free call a triple eight
eight
two five five two two five kendra is
with us kendra's in san antonio texas
kendra it says on my
screen you are debt free congratulations
thank you dave i'm very happy to be
making this phone call right now
that's awesome how much have you paid
off well i paid off 59
1339 in about five years
good for you and your range of income
during that five years
i ranged from about 32 to 52.
wow what do you do for a living i'm an
environmental scientist
okay very good what kind of debt was the
59 000
well i had about 38 of school loans
and 21 of my car payment
okay all right so this was a struggle
for you wasn't it
it was um yeah i just kept
working hard and putting as much as i
could towards that
i got a good chunk of change from uh
some recent hail damage storm
so it made about 8k cosmetic damage
and i put it towards my car loan instead
so
and that cleaned it up the rest of the
way huh oh yeah
it definitely helped so it's got some
dents but i have it paid off and that's
that matters more to me so that's the
big next step yeah well done
well done thank you so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
well just keep keep working hard and
putting as much as you can
afford to to those loans and stay
motivated
i had a great support system my my
brother and his wife
are debt free they paid off a huge chunk
they went through a financial piece and
they they really helped me along the way
yeah i mean you pay off ten thousand
dollars a year for five
years making 32
that's impressive like that's a long
haul what was the hardest part
um i guess just
making sacrifices seeing that
pair of shoes that you really wanted and
just send all control and just
really putting everything towards those
loans
yeah staying motivated that's good how
does it feel now that you're there
it feels incredible was it worth the
sacrifice
absolutely and i didn't think i'd
be here at my age making this phone call
right now how old are you i'm 28.
28 years old and you did this over five
years so you started when you were 23.
yes sir wow very impressive very
impressive
thank you well done definitely helped me
a lot
so appreciate it so your brother and
sister-in-law were
cheerleaders because they had been
through financial peace university who
else was cheering you on
uh definitely my mom and my dad so
okay that's good news she had good
family support because sometimes family
goes you're crazy you're always gonna be
a dad
yeah some people some people have family
that are losers right
and uh you got you got winners that are
encouraging you and lifting you up
that's
very very cool well congratulations
kendra well done thank you thank you
we've got a copy of rachel cruz's latest
new york times
bestseller it's called know yourself
know your money kelly will send that out
to you to say thanks for being on and
doing your debt
free scream i'm so proud of you you're a
rock star
well done thank you dave all right
kendra in san antonio texas
59 000 paid off in
five years making 32-52
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm dead
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it works right there that is
impressive over five years that's a long
time to sacrifice that's a long time to
stay motivated that's a long time to
stay focused like
two years is long but five years man
that's impressive that she stuck with it
that's awesome
and you know the good news when you're
working this stuff and you're single is
you don't talk anybody else into it the
bad news is there's nobody there to kick
your butt no accountability yeah nobody
there to encourage you when you're down
yeah and nobody nobody to hold you in
there and i mean she did that
over five years and her only
accountability
encouragement was her family walking
with her but
i mean it's easier to cheat when you're
single yes and to just give up on the
plan you're like oh this is too hard
i've
i've done it for a period of time i've
made progress but gosh it's just i just
want to buy the shoes like she said and
she just stuck with it that's just so
awesome
that's very well done very very well
done that is awesome stuff
zach is with us zach is in rockford
illinois hi zach
welcome to the ramsay show and thank you
dave
christie nice to be talking with you how
are you guys doing better than we
deserve what's up
well i am on baby step two and i am
debating on whether or not i should
refinance my house
or sell it and move back into an
apartment so i don't have to worry about
any home repairs
do you have home repairs you expect are
there things your maintenance issues
right now
so right now not really anything like
major
i mean my furnace is about 15 years
water heater's five
i just had to pay for a chimney flashing
repair but it's an older house
so that's kind of where i'm currently
debating i mean i've been in it for two
years if i would have taken
financial peace university before i
bought the home
i wouldn't have bought the home but i
took it four months after
but now with the market why would you
have not bought the home after financial
peace because of where you were in the
baby steps or because it's a bad buy
where i was in the baby steps it was
actually a pretty decent buy
uh at the current time i'm saying
why would you have not bought the home
you said if you took financial peace
university first you would not have
bought it did i understand you're right
yeah i would i wouldn't have bought it
because i was in debt
oh i should he's in babysitter yeah yeah
okay that's what i meant yeah all right
cool all right so but now you're out and
you're working on the house right
uh no no i'm still in baby step two so i
got seventy two thousand dollars
in student loans um and with the market
the way it is
i have twenty thousand dollars of equity
in the house
just because of the market so i'm trying
to figure out if i should
sell or refinance
why would you refinance so i am
currently in a 30 year
so um you know i would have did that
differently back then
but it's at 4.25 okay and after talking
to mortgage broker uh i could probably
get a 2.8
to a three percent interest rate yeah if
you're going to stay in the house
you're going to stay in the house get in
touch with churchill mortgage and do a
refi
because you can you can get down under
three right now on a 15 year fixed
while you're at it put it on a 15. um
how old are you i am 27.
and what do you make a year did you tell
me already i have not i'm
currently on pace for 60 to 65 so i'm in
sales
so how much is your house commission
right now it's 646. it wouldn't move a
lot off of that because you're going to
drop two percent down but you're going
to kick from a 30 to 15. it'll move up a
little but not much yeah it's only about
a hundred dollars more
yeah um
the house is the last thing we sell
i'll sell your car in a heartbeat your
boat in a heartbeat your motorcycle in a
heartbeat
they're easier to get out of and into
moving
is emotionally and financially very
expensive
it just takes up a lot of your headspace
to move
and um so it's the last thing i would do
and i have a sense that you're just
starting
your financial peace journey am i right
i started about two years ago but you
guys were just mentioning the single
part
so i slowed down a little bit but i
re-kicked everything into gear i'm not
throwing
two thousand dollars a month towards
debt yeah um so
are you are you are you asking about
selling because you just want to make a
big huge dent in your debt
like is that where the question's coming
from yeah and just not having any stress
with like
the repairs would be on the apartment
complex i mean i did the math of
you know also considering the water bill
and the electricity
yeah well let me tell you over the scope
of your life you can do the math renting
does not keep up with owning owning is
better even with the chimney flashing
okay over the scope of your life not a
short-term situation sometimes
owning will be more expensive than
renting uh
so i think you've just had a repair and
you've got a re
uh juvenated desire to get out and those
two things are combining to push you to
sell it i'm gonna tell you to keep it
for now
uh in the spring next year if you're
still
limping with this thing a little bit you
may want to sell it but i think you're
going to refinance it and keep it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we take your calls
about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five mason is with us mason is
in lansing michigan hi mason how are you
hey how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um so i'm 22 years old and i'm currently
living in my parents house
and i want to achieve financial freedom
through
entrepreneurship or starting a uh
self-storage business and i have five
thousand dollars saved up and i don't
know what to do with my next step
a self what business storage
storage self storage well that's a bit
of an expensive transaction dude let's
talk about buying a big piece of
commercial real estate
uh probably not your first step
why why that out of curiosity
um i know uh a few people in my family
who
they who've had success in there um
they're distant relatives so i don't
have a lot of contact with them but
um i know that they have a decent amount
of money off of that oh it's a cash cash
once you get it up and get it running
it's a cash cow but we're talking about
you know whatever it takes a half
million million dollars to get this
thing
planted in the ground baby i mean this
is no small step here
that that's usually something you would
do after you've gotten something else
going
so your drive is just to make money
right now
um to practically yeah
yeah so you said entrepreneurship what
are you thinking of there
um i'm not sure i've looked into
quite a few uh different sections
but i i haven't landed like pinpointed
myself in a direction yet
what do you get excited about like what
what kind of things get you excited
because
the self storage business well it's not
a bad idea that you want to
make money and your family has done it
uh business can be hard
and so looking deeper for a deeper
passion
than just money and success those things
will come what what are you passionate
about what are you excited about what
what
what keeps you up at night because you
man that's so fun i want to work on that
i want to help these people i want to
solve this problem
that's that's the heart of
entrepreneurship is solving problems and
helping people
what is that for you um
well i do i do like before i got onto
that entrepreneurship
trail i was a mechanic and i love
working on cars and helping out people
that way
okay what have you been doing up to this
point
what kind of work um well like i said i
was uh
i was a mechanic but do you covet i got
laid off and i've been working at a
local grocery store stock
shelves i make about 16 an hour
i love your ambition uh as a serial
entrepreneur
myself i started cutting grass when i
was 12 years old had 27 yards to cut
i've always had a p
l in my life uh and so i love what
you're trying to do i love where your
head's at
christy teaches uh men and women all
over the world
how to start and how to operate
businesses is what she does she's
excellent at it
um and i think both of us are stepping
back and going
uh let me let me ask you this have you
ever been someplace
and a salesman was trying to sell you
something
and it felt slimy
yes like he was there trying to make a
commission and didn't care about
you yes
yeah that's what an entrepreneur is that
starts a business
just to make money
you smell bad and you don't mean for it
to mason it doesn't start out you don't
no but you're you're in it for you
instead of them
and so what you've got to figure out is
is there has to be a problem
that you're looking for in the world
that god puts you on the planet to solve
that
problem for people and it could be
the most honest uh mechanic
in the world and you end up owning a
hundred
shops all over america with your name on
them fixing cars 10 years from now i
don't know
it could be something else but somewhere
there's a problem
that when you solve it for someone it
clicks in your soul and
makes you smile oh and i can make money
not i'll do anything to make money
because let me tell you that that i'll
do anything to make money is what's
driving the storage
thing you had no passion about that at
all all you're to do is get some money
and we can hear in your voice you're
just trying to get some money and that's
never going to work
business business people who just try to
get money smell bad
it's all going to give up and when
things get hard because they will get
hard you're going to give up because
that's not enough to keep you going
let me give you a couple areas of your
life to look at mason as you explore
this
what are your strengths these are things
you're naturally good at what are your
skills any education experience the car
mechanic would be an example of
experience
what stuff do you have do you have
certain equipment you could use or
a laptop or a certain facility you can
use for a business idea
what would it was social what would you
do socially just for fun what would you
do as a hobby just because you love it
just because you enjoy it
look at your story your backstory is
there something that man you had a
really tough season of life or something
you went through that that could inspire
a passion
for helping people my mom starting a
bakery when i was six months old
is part of my story that's my passion
behind business boutique
look at your skills your strengths your
stuff your story
your uh what you would do socially and
look at some of these things you already
have in you
to try to dig out in mind for what is
something that is a business idea i
could get excited about and don't get
overwhelmed by their there's only one
idea
just start with an idea that could work
try some stuff and see what works but
you need to be excited about it if
you're going to stick with it for the
long haul
and if you're not going to feel salesy
and desperate
for money which is what dave was talking
about so start with some of those i call
them my s's these are my
my five s's start with some of those s's
and let that
give you direction for maybe a business
idea that you'd be more excited about
than the storage right now and more cost
effective by the way
now nothing smells quite as bad as a
broke salesperson or a greedy
salesperson
and when you open a business and you're
all about what money you can extract
from the customer that's the spirit
you're operating in
and that's what you want to avoid and
the problem is there's nothing evil
about wanting to
be ambitious and wanting to win and
going want to go i'm going to want to
start a business i'm going to go in the
marketplace and succeed
i want you to do all of that but what is
the problem that you're going to solve
that
we can't keep you from doing it once you
get lit on fire
i mean when i started doing the very
first thing i ever did with money was i
was just counseling people at our church
as a ministry for free helping people
that were in foreclosure stop a
foreclosure help them get on a budget
after we went broke i had a heart for
hurting people right that were where
sharon and i had been
and i had the skills to stop to help
them right and i was doing it for free
right uh you couldn't keep me from doing
it yeah and
uh you know now it's a 350 million
dollar business
right you know and uh but it started
with that and that's also why i can't be
canceled
because i won't stop yeah i don't need
someone's approval
to do this i don't need someone's
admiration
to do this i don't even need their money
to do this i'll just go
i'm gonna do it anyway i'm just gonna do
it yeah and then what that does is it
pierces through the darkness and pierces
through the bs
yeah that is out there in business but
the first time you hit a hard roadblock
like christie said
folks out there running a business you
quit yeah if
if you if you're not if your butt's not
burning if you ain't got this thing in
your stomach or you're just wired up man
and you just can't be denied you i'm
going you know it's not about
me being rich no that's a by-product
yeah and i think people miss it because
they focus on what they get
not on what they give business and life
by the way is focusing on what you give
you give value solutions help to people
i see this all the time dave at our
events i'll have someone come through my
book signing line and they'll say
i want to do what you do i want to be a
speaker and every time i'll say
why because if if they don't have an
answer of like i want to help these
people i want to solve these problems
then they're in it for the spotlight
they're in it for the followers doing it
for the fame
they want the admiration your audience
will feel that you can tell the
difference between a speaker who walks
on a stage
and they're looking for what they can
get i can i get a laugh can i get a
standing ovation
versus a speaker that comes on stage and
says i want to give value i want to give
solutions and it's the same
in business if you are in it for what
you can get
your customers will feel it and if
you're in it for what you can give
your customers will feel it our friend
ken blanchard says profit
is the applause that your customers give
you
well done well done
that's what they're saying it's a wrap
by product of it mason that's a really
good question i'm so glad you called in
to ask it
and you probably got more than you
bargained for but
i i predict good things in your future
sir you're a sharp young man
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the box
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book
business boutique and host of the
christy wright podcast which is
a big exploding movement i is my co-host
today as we answer your questions the
phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two
five ryan is with us to start off this
hour in
waterbury connecticut hey ryan how are
you
good dave how you doing better than i
deserve sir what's up
um i'm 27 years old and i'm on baby
steps four and six
and i was wondering if it would be
ridiculous or
wise to stop making extra payments on my
mortgage
to save up and build a basketball court
in my backyard
a basketball court in your backyard
what does like a real court like like
not just like a goal like an actual
court
yeah like a concrete slab oh my
like a a full court or half court do a
half
half a half okay um
what would it cost uh
between three and six grand and um
what uh what do you make a year
uh last year i made 65 but this year i'm
looking to make closer to 85. what's
your house worth
uh 228 okay and you just love i'm just
curious why you just love basketball you
want to play all the time
yeah or is this just kind of like a
ridiculous thing to do
because i'm trying to be wise you know
and build wealth and i was planning on
paying the house off within five to
seven years
um but other than that i was just
curious on you know i mean it's no it's
not ridiculous i mean people put tennis
courts in their backyard
people put pools in their backyard they
do all kinds of things
let's talk about it from a real estate
perspective no it's not ridiculous but
let's talk through is there a
is there a better way to do this than a
and a worse way to do this and the
answer is yeah i think there is probably
from a real
estate person's perspective is how i'm
going to put that hat on for a minute
um yeah i'm going to build it
if i if i'm doing this the for the least
money possible number one
because it's not going to add a dime of
value to the house
right so like if you spend six thousand
dollars the house is not worth six
thousand dollars more because of it
as a matter of fact if you do it poorly
the house might be less marketable
because it's kind of got this weird
thing in the backyard for somebody that
doesn't play basketball
right that's what i was that's what i
was worried about down the line
like i looked at a really nice vacation
property the other day
that like a super super nice one i don't
play
tennis and it had a fabulous tennis
court in the backyard
and i kind of looked at that as a
negative not a positive
it's like a thing back there that i
don't need or want
and you know it's like a like a problem
not a not an opportunity so
that's a if you do it wrong that's how
you do it so depending on how you're
i mean i'm just thinking about
properties that i've owned or lived in
number one growing up in nashville we
had
turnarounds you back out of the garage
and you drive away and most of the
neighborhood kids including
when my kids were little we had a nice
turnaround that was paved
in our case it wasn't concrete and we
put a basketball goal on the house or
put one on a pole
on the edge of the turnaround and it
didn't really
a cost anything extra to put the actual
surface in
it was a little bit of money to put a
goal up but b
it didn't weird people out there weren't
basketball people when they came to buy
the house they just went well i'll take
the pole down right if i don't like one
don't worry back
and so do you have like a turnaround you
could do that with
i don't but my other idea was to
build a patio on the back of the house
you know
closer to the house and it would be a
smaller patio but also
i could play basketball on it and then
that would be the same kind of thing
that makes a lot more sense and then you
you know and then the
buyer can visualize i'm just going to
pull the goal out or you could even pull
the goal out yourself
before you put it on the market and then
you've just got a nice patio you built
now we're not messing with the
marketability of the house okay and that
is less weird the only other thing i can
think of is
i don't again a driveway configuration
matters here
but if you don't have a turnaround if
you have a
your driveway pulls up and you can
simply extend the driveway back
and put the pad there it gives
additional parking spaces or maybe a
slab to put an extension
or to put a a an exterior garage on
some day if it wasn't a basketball court
that kind of thing so we've got again
like like the patio thing it's got
multiple uses right
so i i just want you thinking that way
don't stick it back there and make it a
problem for the buyer
how long are you planning to stay in
this house out of curiosity
uh well i wanted to pay it off as soon
as possible
and that looks about five to seven years
and then my plan was to either
use it as a rental or you know resell it
and move up in house
gotcha okay okay so yeah yeah i think
you just
use some of these ideas we're batting
around here and try to make it a
a multi-use type of thing yeah where
it's got possible other uses so it
doesn't just look like a
problem concrete slab in the backyard
yeah yeah like
why is that there i wanted to grow
tomatoes there
you know and that you know that that's
what people will that's what that
stinking tennis court i mean
i think it's wonderful if you play
tennis but i don't play tennis well and
even can i turn it into a shooting ring
the thing is the percentage of people
that might buy your house that like
basketball
is small and then the people that would
want to play is even smaller than the
people that would want that in their
backyard is like
tiny yeah so you're talking about a very
small percentage of people that someone
would actually like that so the rest of
the people you're isolating
and it'll turn off build it in such a
way that it can be something else
yeah in addition to that and the least
possible cost as well because you're not
doing that and then
and the more you move in that direction
the less you are
on the ridiculous side and the more you
are on the wise side
there you go good question interesting
chuck's with us in kansas city hi chuck
how are you
i'm doing good thanks babe yeah i i i'm
57
and i just came into some money and i
was wanting to invest it
for retirement and one of the options i
looked at was
indexed annuities and i was curious what
you thought about
that option it's okay
i wouldn't use it for an actual
retirement account because an annuity
grows tax deferred
and a retirement account also grows tax
deferred so it's kind of redundant
in that sense or tax-free if it's a roth
and you're paying an extra fee for it to
be in the annuity
so you just buy the index you buy an
index mutual fund
inside of your roth if you were going to
do that um
the other thing i want you to be aware
of is i don't i'm 60 and i don't use
them
uh because they've got extra fees the
commissions are much higher on them for
the
seller uh the the financial advisor
that's selling them than a simple mutual
fund transaction
and so instead what i do with a lump sum
like that is i invest it just in an
index fund
i use an s p 500 index fund i just drop
some money in there
and it grows without taxes by and large
until you take it out because it's
capital gains growth
it is not dividend growth and they have
what's called a low
turnover ratio so study and learn a
little bit about low turnover ratio
mutual funds that would be my suggestion
but the variable in od as long as it's
got good mutual funds in it is not
horrible
in your situation
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we want to
transform so many lives
that disruption spreads like wildfire
across this country
if you haven't noticed our culture has
become toxic
and the only way to remove that toxicity
is to
displace it with clean
good real ideas imagine a world where
it's weird to have a student loan
that you get an education and you pay
for it imagine a world where the
majority people pay cash for their car
imagine a world where the credit card is
the cigarette of the financial world
imagine a world where ladies
are empowered and know exactly how to
start and run their businesses the way
christy teaches
at ramsey solutions we work on this
level of disruption
every day and it's why we have a just
under a thousand folks on our team right
now
and they create digital products and
services to help people transform their
lives with the goal of disrupting
the toxic culture in america today
and if you want to join us on that
crusade we're currently on the hunt for
software engineers with expertise in
ruby on rails
java c-sharp front-end technologies if
you're a ux
designer an seo content marketing
specialist
uh digital creative we'd love to talk
with you
we've got about 300 jobs we need to fill
this
year to be able to do the different
initiatives
that we've got to help people in america
today
if you want to talk about joining us
find out about all the available jobs by
texting
work that matters to 33 789
text work that matters to 33789 to find
out about our open opportunities
and you can of course also i go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the
right hand tab that says
we are hiring lucy is in california hi
lucy welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can christy and i help
so i actually just started listening to
you about a week and a half ago
and i started the cash envelope system
and started budgeting because i am a
horrible horrible spender
um so i want to change my habits i do
have a student loan
for about 37 000 that i haven't made a
payment to
since 2017 and
i also have a title loan
that i pay about 96 interest and
my principal balance is about 5 000.
um i just because i am
sort of new to this uh budgeting
and i'm trying to be debt free i just
want your advice on how to attack
um these loans that i have because i i
do have a
six-month-old baby that i want to plan
for for her future
good for you so you're a single mom
um no i have a boyfriend okay
all right so you're a single mom okay
okay
and i mean you're not married right no
we're not married
okay and uh what do you make of here
55 000 okay that's good news
well congratulations on stepping up and
saying hey this is an area of my life
that's caused me pain and i want to fix
it i'm proud of you
yeah thank you very very well done very
cool stuff
good for you so um
having sat in this seat for almost 30
years now here's what i think i heard
you say
in the background behind the words um
how old are you 33 33
okay and so you've kind of just lived
your life
and money happened to you you never
happened
to it and the baby comes and you went oh
crap i got to be a grown-up
yeah is that right yeah okay
good for you i'm so proud of you yeah
that's awesome thank you thank you so
much
and i can tell some of that because the
the only way anybody takes out a title
loan is they're
desperate yeah you felt cornered at some
point and out of money and scared
because otherwise you wouldn't have
signed up for 96 interest
everyone knows including you that that
that's not a winning proposition right
yeah no so the great news about your
story is is that once you
once the switch flipped inside your
brain in the last few months
uh and you said no more i've had it i'm
not living like this anymore
you're gonna change things fast so fast
it's gonna be amazing
because you're so ready i don't have to
talk you into stuff you're like over it
am i is that right yes i am okay
completely
well obviously then what we're going to
do is we're going to get on a detailed
type budget
beans and rice rice and beans no life
i don't want you going out to eat i
don't want to hear about a vacation you
have a mess girl and it's time to clean
it up
and we're going to do our whole life
right now is clean up debt
complete focused intensity like
okay okay all right and the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna get rid of
this stupid butt title loan and get
those people out of your life and don't
you ever go back on that property
or call those people ever again the rest
of your life okay i won't i won't ever
in fact you can take your pinky out and
wave it at them as you drive by every
time from now on
because i am never going to go in this
place again they screw people
right no they do for sure and i i know
this because i
am in the financial industry myself but
i
yeah well you had a brain lapse because
you got desperate every time i get
desperate right after that i get stupid
that's what happens to me it happens to
me too and i teach this stuff
so we're going to attack that thing
we're going to be on a detailed written
budget
i'm going to put you into ramsey plus
for one year it's our online access to
everything it's the cadillac the bentley
all right it's going to put you into
financial peace university into the uh
extended version of every dollar the
world's best budgeting app
i'm going to pay for all of it it's
going to be free for you
but you have to promise me you're going
to get in there and do everything we
tell you to do
and one year from today you're going to
have a completely different life if you
do that
oh my god yes
i'm sorry i told you she was ready
didn't i yeah
yeah you're awesome i am so proud of you
so you go through financial peace
university you drag boyfriend in there
by the ear
and uh tell him he's gonna watch it with
you and we're gonna start getting our
act together and get our life
together and get this stress off of you
okay you're gonna do this lucy and when
you do i want you to call us back
and you tell us your story and you do
your debt-free scream okay
oh my god yes you're gonna do this we've
been binge watching on youtube i've been
listening to your podcast and
um he has a sprained ankle right now so
he was stuck with me in my room all day
yesterday while i was working
and i said i'm going to play this
because this is what i've been listening
to while i work
and he's also been so motivated and he's
like wow this just
puts you like in the right mind like you
know we want to buy a house and
want to start a savings for our baby
girl so
i mean i think he's he's better with his
money than
i am but um i'm so ready for this thank
you guys so much you don't even know
how much i appreciate this well we are
honored to help you
it's what we do and you hang on kelly
will pick up we'll get you signed up and
you call us back
anytime you need help while you're
walking through this and call us back
and
when you score the touchdown and let us
know and we'll do your debt free scream
with you how fun
that is so cool i love that her
boyfriend was a captive audience and
she's like your ankle is sprained i'm
just going to play the dave ramsey
show for
hey that's going to be our new answer of
how to get people to break their pages
break their ankle hobble them hobble
them and they can't how do i get my
spouse on board you hit their ankle with
a sledgehammer and then just press play
that's great i love it that's awesome
les brown the great motivator i was i
did an event with him about i was
walking through the hallway my picture
with him back here the other day
and i stopped and looked at it because
he's such a good man he lives over in
l.a
and um he just says you have to be
hungry
you know you have to be sick and tired
of being sick and tired
and people change their lives when they
say i've had it
i've had it i've had it
and you know what no amount of intellect
offsets that no
no amount of academic discussion of some
freaking
theory offsets that you have to get this
belly burning thing happening where you
go that's it
i'm not living like this anymore this
sucks
and when you change that that's when it
changes
your my favorite quote of you is you can
wander into debt you cannot wander out
you gotta get
mad i love it you gotta get fired up man
and it's just a decision and that's
where lucy is she just decided
and then we stumbled across her path how
serendipitous
thank you lord
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we talk to you about your life and
your money in the lobby of ramsey
solutions
on the debt free stage baby they're here
nick and brody are with us uh which can
only mean one thing they're debt-free
hey guys
hi hi christy hi dave hi where do you
guys live
nome alaska wow quite a trek
you win the furthest travel for a
debt-free scream award
oh my gosh wow very cool and any excuse
to get down south huh
right it was negative 30 with wind chill
when we left
which is unseasonably cold but wow can't
breathe we're melting man well i'm so
glad you're here how much do you pay off
267 800 845
wow how long did that take
well um it took nine and a half years
okay and your range of income during
that decade
we started off at 75 000 went up to 150
and then down to 124. okay
what kind of debt was this i'm guessing
with that length of time and that amount
of money you might have paid off your
house
we did we did wow look at the weird
people
oh how old are you two weird people i
was
35 when we paid it off we paid it off uh
three weeks before my 36th birthday
there you go
and i'm 39. ding ding well done you guys
what are you do in gnome alaska i'm a
court administrator
and i work for an airline okay very cool
now i've been to anchorage where is
gnome i can't see it in my head
it's uh northwest of anchorage about 500
miles oh just a wee bit
you can only of anchorage alaska where
do you live
north of anchorage yes okay that'll work
wow
okay yeah well you can only fly half the
places in alaska i heard you have more
airline there are more people that have
airline light air
pilot slices than driver's license
wow man very cool so what's this house
worth
two hundred and twenty thousand dollars
was what we paid for it yeah it's at
least 260 now yeah yeah
very good and was the 268 all the
mortgage
or other things too we had about 47 000
in consumer debt when we first started
um paid that all off and in about seven
months
and then we uh lived life for a while
and
after paying uh off that debt we moved
we uh cash flowed that move um
we bought a house
we saved for the down payment for this
house and then
in 2015 we bought this house and
uh we really weren't focused on paying
off like we were doing our budget every
month
and uh we were throwing extra at the
principal but
i don't think either of us nick brought
home a thermometer
for us to fill in every time we paid it
off we'd fill it in a little bit much
a lot of people do that but it takes on
a new meaning in nome alaska
well when nick brought it home it just
felt overwhelming um
it just was there was a lot of lines
right
it didn't seem like we were making much
progress on it
and i think when it really kicked in
was december of 2018
when we decided to throw a chunk of
money at it
and we were at the halfway mark
and i can see the light like oh we can
do this
and um before um we really became
focused around three and a half years
ago when our daughter was born our
oldest
and we're like why are we just you know
we're not really focused on the house
we're doing all these other things
buying gear there's so much gear that
you can buy for things in alaska outdoor
gear
crafts and snow machines snow machines
and
four-wheeler i mean just you name it and
it's all expensive it's really
cheap and so we'd been cash flowing
those different things and then when our
daughter was born we were like
um at different times before that we'd
kind of look at each other and be like
are you ready to pay off really focus
and one of us would be like no look
squirrel i want that thing over there
let's do that thing then we'll do it
yeah then we'll do it but once our
daughter was born we really dug in
and uh and we paid it off in february of
this year
so how does it feel to be 35 39 years
old with a paid for house
i don't know if it's really sunk in yet
we just paid it off in february and so
april 1st was our first budget meeting
where we didn't have a mortgage payment
for march or april and so that i think
it's starting to sink in but we're not
we haven't fully realized it's a lot of
money yeah
yeah it's a lot of money wow good for
you i'm so proud of you
thanks very cool who are your biggest
cheerleaders
oh man you know we were pretty private
about the journey
um we've certainly talked to our friends
about it and
the friends that we've talked to have
all been
like wow you guys are doing it that's
awesome and
but um our parents have been supportive
my mom's taken financial peace
university we've taught a couple
financial
university courses thank you um so
that keeps you on track it really did
when you start teaching it you have to
do it
yeah you could go to the class and sort
of do it but when you teach it you have
to do it
yeah it forced us to do an insurance
double check
oh there you go yeah we had some
updating to do on all that too
yeah very good very good what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is
uh for me with the house it was really
patience
because we had you know been cash
flowing things for a while and
um having that large number and
just breaking it down into small chunks
and being able to just be patient and
wait
um yeah how do you eat an elephant a
bite at a time
yeah that thermometer one line at a time
yeah that's so interesting too because
research shows that seeing progress is
the most motivating thing and once you
guys got to the halfway mark like it
gave you that extra push so it's just so
cool to see how
those small things all added up to you
guys sticking with it
well done that's amazing yeah you just
won't you won't stick with it if you
don't see the progress
and that's that's good the incremental
wins that's so good you guys
you did it you are that free house and
everything
completely so weird i love it
and you brought the kiddos with you to
do the debt-free scream what are their
names and ages
this is lydia she is three and a half
years old
sweet and this is adrian
she turned one a week after we paid off
the house
wow that's awesome we've got a pretty
lydia in our family too
not much older than that oh yeah very
cool you guys congratulations we've got
a copy of rachel cruz's
book for you her latest new york times
bestseller know yourself know your money
nick and brodie and lydia and adrian
268 000 paid off in nine
and a half years 75 to 150 to 124
house and everything they are weird
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's so cool wow gosh her face it was
like just the joy it was just like you
could feel it man
oh my gosh well what people don't
realize is when you don't have that
payment
it's a math thing for a while it's kind
of an emotional thing for a while
but when it's gone it's a spiritual
thing yeah you feel something click
in the spirit you know and you're like i
had no idea i was a slave and now i'm
not
yeah the borrower is slave to the lender
there's something
yeah the freedom in that there's a
release yeah like that breath of cold
mountain air
yeah you probably don't use cold air in
their example with gnome alaska but
yeah there's a sense of cleanliness
going down into your lungs you know i
mean there's this like i'm
wow i'm in a whole different place yeah
because you are yeah yeah you're set up
to win and that's just the first step
that's right you're living like no one
else so that later you can live
and give like no one else so you can put
yourself in a position to win like
you've
never done before and completely change
those babies family tree
what great what a great young couple
rock stars that's awesome that is so
fun this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey it's magic
you'll get the best
deal today's question comes from shelly
in ohio
i'm a 52 year old woman with a ba in art
and mba and management i've been a stay
at home mom for the last 10 years but
i'm ready to go back to work
i'd love to get into interior design
however most jobs require
design training which i don't have our
community college offers a two-year
course and i can cash flow their program
is this something worth doing at my age
this is such an interesting question and
i think there's some different
variables that i want to point out first
of all at her age i'm like
absolutely you can do that if you want
to and you can cash flow but what's more
interesting to me is
if you think you want to do it i
encourage people to do this a lot
how can you get some experience in that
to make sure you want to do it before
you go take the courses because even if
you have to have some
uh education and training in this to do
you know a full
uh interior design full-time job it
doesn't mean you have to have that in
order to get started or to intern or to
shadow or to
have some position where you could make
sure this is what you want to do
before you do it so i would encourage
maybe a baby step but as far as her age
i'm like no you absolutely
can do that people switch careers they
have encore careers what's the example
of the um
colonel sanders 63 years old before he
ever um
fried his first chicken brought his
first chicken yeah yeah i mean there's a
lot of
grandma moses never paid a painting
until she was 88 years old she did 1500
works of art before she died at 100.
and so you're not done do you quit don't
talk to me about your age you're 52 i'm
60 you're pissing me off
so you're not done here you're not done
but the um
you know the thing on interior design uh
there's so many ways to get at that
and there are many many many world-class
designers who never had a class on
interior design
they just they had an eye for it a knack
for it and they developed it
over time they studied with and around
other people but they didn't necessarily
go get a degree in interior design
there's a lot of them
uh that do very very well and and you've
got an mba in business so you know to
run the business part
uh so i i'm with you i think i would use
that ken coleman proximity principle
and let's find an interior designer in
your area and
even if uh you did something really
weird uh you're not making any money
right now
so why don't you just go work for them
for free for 90 days and say i want to
prove that i'm worth having me around
uh and then work for them for a year and
learn how they do what they do
you're probably going to figure out that
you can pick fabric
yeah without a two-year degree that's
probably going to figure out you can
pick a paint color
without a two-year degree and maybe
maybe there's some for example maybe
there's some program that a lot of
interior designers use
to mock up what a room would look like
to present to a potential client you
learn that on the job or you learn that
in this
uh company that you don't have to go get
a degree to do anyway so even if there
is some technical aspect that you want
to know that would help
you you might be able to just learn it
there yeah almost in an apprentice
type of a setting use that proximity
principle yeah i'm with you i think i'd
get my feet wet
um i don't think what you need is more
education i think you need some
confidence
that's right you're looking for
confidence and it's not found in
education
it's amazing how many people ask me such
a similar question dave
of well i need to go get another degree
and another degree and another degree
and what they're really looking for is
permission they're waiting for some
piece of paper that's going to give them
permission
like you don't need permission to go do
this thing
to go try this thing to go help people
and learn the the degree
you think is going to be your gateway of
permission and more often than not it's
you actually doing the thing that makes
you feel the confidence you're looking
for
you have a four-year degree in art if
you decide you're an interior designer
you just are one
you just decided that's right print you
some business cards baby that's right
and then go pick some paint colors and
will you get better over time yeah will
you stumble around a little bit
yeah you don't know how to necessarily
source the lines of furniture or the
fabrics or the paintings or whatever is
needed
to decorate that home and make it look
like magazine city but
i think you probably know enough to
start today
but if you want to build a little
confidence go work for somebody for a
little bit
and and getting your feet wet will give
you not only the confidence but it'll
give you the skills
dave i think i took one class in college
on speaking and that's just because it
was a part of
my business management program you know
how i learned how to be a speaker is by
speaking for the last 10 years yeah
and reviewing and every time you did a
talk
watching the video watching and looking
at surveys learning watching from other
people
it's just brutal to watch yourself yes
it is you know you go back and review
your own work
in any work you'll find the errors more
than anybody else will find them and
you'll correct course correct course
great get better get better get better
that's called experience and um but you
know how you become a writer you're
right
that's right you know you become a
speaker you speak you know how you
become an interior designer you and do
interior design that's right
and uh so i i there's not a license
required
uh you don't need permission you can
just go but
if you need more confidence then
uh we've decorated oh i can't think
i can't count now thoroughly decorated
and or
redecorated using five different
decorators
over the years uh or interior designers
over the years
and some of them with big time
credentials some of them without
uh but you know what we cared about we
didn't care a thing about their
credentials what we cared about was
the work that they had done and we're
going to do can you do a good job
and can i get there and that's all i
cared about yeah i didn't know
you know as a matter of fact i kind of
preferred they didn't have
uh a long list of letters after their
name from
some school in france because that means
they're going to charge me triple to
pick to go i need a white wall while i
already knew they needed a white wall
you know i mean so don't you know i just
i i didn't
you know it was less joy for me that way
more joy for sharon probably but less
joy for me
so uh and that's not to say you can't
learn
things from um in that field but
but um but getting started is probably
your best bet
yeah it's good it's a big deal uh
melissa is in boise idaho hi melissa
welcome to the ramsey show thank you hi
dave and christie
hi um hi i moved from california to
idaho in 2017 and now i have a job i
really love but i kept my house in
california and i
plan to retire in four years and maybe
move back
but what i'm thinking now is should i
keep the house for the whole four years
sell it and then put it into an
investment property
and then just and pay cash for it and
let it cash flow
and then i just ran and live around and
travel around or is it better to just
have that as my primary residence or
would you recommend i didn't sell it now
i'll show it now
like that because i wouldn't long
distance landlord for 20 seconds
it's a nightmare and i don't know i
don't know i own a bunch of rental
property and i don't recommend it
i just i don't recommend it and i don't
know what california real estate is
going to do
it has done well in the past um
obviously
it has also been uh in my lifetime of 40
years
working lifetime of 40 years watching
real estate it has been the most
volatile market overall
uh meaning it goes way up and then it
busts and goes way up and then it busts
and with the number of people leaving
that state right now
i don't know what's going to happen to
prices there
i'm a little shocked honestly with the
level of the level of
exodus from california that prices
haven't already gotten soft there
but they haven't they're having it
they're white hot they they're quite hot
so no inventory yeah yeah no it's no
inventory we're in the united states i
mean uh
so the kovacs even though you play
recapture right now because if i
right now i'm using it as my primary and
paying california taxes and my
doing a roommate situation and gave him
reduced rent
and i think if i wait until january to
sell it i won't have to pay 56 000 a
recapture or would you just take this
january
50 but i'm not gonna keep it five years
and
you know i wouldn't have kept it in the
first place and so i'm gonna begin the
process of divesting and saying
you know i'm gonna live in idaho my
investments are gonna be in idaho and
when i leave idaho my investments will
also leave idaho
and um that that's what i would have you
to do
um it's not it's all
almost never i mean so close to never
that i can just say never
a good idea to become a landlord by
default
in other words would you have gone and
bought that house to use it as rental
property while you lived in idaho
answer one thousand times is no
i live in idaho i'm gonna go to buy a
house that looks like something i would
live in in california
for rental no you wouldn't do that and
so since you wouldn't do that then
keeping it is becoming a landlord by
default and it seldom turns out to be a
great decision
seldom i mean can you get out of it make
some money yeah yeah
if you can 56 000 help on the recapture
by january fine i'm good with that
but but long term i'm not holding that
puppy thank you for the call
christy good show thanks so much thanks
for having me this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage may mean you're
an everyday millionaire
it's an everyday millionaire's theme
hour we want you to call in if you're a
real millionaire we're gonna talk to you
this hour
and for the rest of you we're going to
teach you what real millionaires do
not what your broke brother-in-law
thinks
and not what some idiot hack political
person
with an axe to grind who wants us to
move towards socialism thinks
we're going to teach you where real
millionaires come from
spoiler alert you can do it
you can do it when you live like no one
else
later you can live as a millionaire
and give like no one else
now because there are political idiots
out there
and people who have entered the
conversation in the name of wealth
equality or
inequality or whatever the discussion
needs to be
with that we have to address a couple of
basic definitions
millionaire is an accounting term
you don't get to make up your own
definition there is a
singular one definition that is the
truth
a millionaire is not someone that makes
a million dollars a year
a millionaire is not someone that has a
million dollars cash
although that person could also be a
millionaire
millionaire refers to billionaire also
refers to net worth
your net worth is what you own
minus what you owe
now various people in different
accounting functions will
include some assets and don't include
some assets
i mean you can put your clothing in
there if you want but your clothing's
not really worth anything so that's a
bunch of crap
okay so but what do you actually own
that you can turn into money
and what do you owe what you own
minus what you owe your assets minus
your liabilities equals your net worth
when you do that in that bottom right
hand corner
that number is a million dollars or
greater you are a millionaire
it's not a feeling i don't feel like a
millionaire it doesn't matter
million dollars isn't enough anymore
doesn't matter
we're not discussing feelings and we're
not discussing what's enough we're
telling you how
you become a millionaire it's when you
have a one million dollar or greater net
worth does it solve all your problems
well crap no it actually brings you new
ones
okay does it but but one problem you
don't have is you can afford the tylenol
for the headache
okay one problem you don't have is you
don't have to worry about putting
tires on your car anymore one problem
you don't have is you're not going to
retire and
retire and count on social insecurity to
take care of your butt
which is an absolute nightmare you
actually have
some money that's what a millionaire is
so we're gonna talk to real millionaires
ask them what they did how it's made up
and how they got there
because there's a lot of mythology
around millionaires
the phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five
five i don't care how you became a
millionaire
i want to talk to you because we want to
tell real people what
real millionaires do how they did it
so that real people can say i want to do
it that way if all of you won the
lottery
then we'll all line up for the lottery
which by the way that isn't how it
worked okay
but you know whatever it is we want to
copy you millionaires so we can be one
of you
that's the purpose of this hour the
everyday
millionaire theme hour clint is our
first millionaire up
in chattanooga tennessee hi clint how
are you
i'm doing great dave how are you better
than i deserve what's your net worth
uh 1.3 million good for you
break that down for me by category how
much in your retirement how much in your
house and so forth
uh we've got about 620 000 in retirement
savings
we've got between our home and a piece
of land we own that's about 380 000
and we've got 300 000 in cash and
other savings good for you well done how
old are you
37 years old wow young millionaire so
how much of this did you inherit sir
none zero and what was your range of
income your best working year and your
worst working year
best would have been last year we made
about 225 000
and worse would have been when we first
got married we started at about 84 000.
what do you guys do for a living what do
you do i'm a
vice president of a construction company
in the estimating side
and my wife she's a quality manager
at a major carpet manufacturer gotcha
and you have a four-year degree we do we
both have bachelor's degrees okay what's
your degree in
uh construction management and
brittany's is in industrial engineering
and
you're both using it good what's your
gpa what was your gpa in college
uh we were mid threes nothing real good
but nothing real bad either
gotcha okay how much of this 1.3 million
dollars in net worth at 37 years old do
you think you have because you borrowed
money to create wealth
well i i learned about you my senior
year of college
and i've seen debt as the arch enemy of
wealth
since then so zero zero so you haven't
leveraged your way into this so to speak
okay no sir all right you did this
really quick
i'm very proud of you very impressive so
there's a 22 year old guy
who's in construction management
listening to you right now
how did you do this in 15 years
what do you tell him well my my mom
was going through financial peace
university and handed me the cds
from the class and said you need to
listen to this guy um
and it clicked as soon as i listened to
it and um
i would say probably uh the number one
thing would be choose your spouse wisely
because
yeah yeah if you've got somebody that's
willing to lock arms with you and
claw scrape sacrifice to meet any goal
there's really nothing you can't do and
if you can eliminate the number one
cause of divorce in your marriage
early on then you know the other things
are minuscule compared to that so
yeah that's so impressive that's very
very insightful
um okay so sometimes people think that
if you did this this quick
um that that you have had no life during
the last 15 years do you all go on
vacations
and have you enjoyed your life during
the last 15 years
no absolutely there's there's portions
of the baby steps where
you know you're you're sacrificing the
fun of life
at times but we we do plenty of things
and right now we do pretty much anything
we want to do
yeah i guess so man congratulations yeah
you're making a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year not a payment in the
world a million three net worth
37 so that means that my guesstimate is
you're probably going to be worth 10 to
20 million dollars at 65.
that would be the goal yeah that's kind
of mind-blowing
starting from nothing so it absolutely
can
be done that's the moral of the story
folks so there he is
a construction management guy he's not a
star in the nba
he doesn't have his own state farm
commercial
[Music]
you don't know his name
and at 37 years old he's worth 1.3
million dollars
i'm telling you folks you can do this
and i'm going to continue to show you
you can do it
and i'm going to continue to punch
people in the mouth that say you can't
do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
this is the ramsey show we're talking to
real
millionaires mythology is out there
about where wealth comes from in america
by the way you will hear on this show
and you will hear from
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in north america airtight research
that the vast majority of millionaires
did not
inherit their wealth as a matter of fact
79
of the millionaires were inherited zero
another five percent inherited a small
amount like five thousand dollars not
enough to make any difference at all
towards becoming a millionaire and
another five percent
inherited money after they were already
millionaires so let me help you that 79
plus 10 is 89
that's 9 out of 10 millionaires are not
millionaires
because of inherited money that's a
statistical
fact not a fruit loop writing a blog in
his mother's basement
what's that matter it matters because
you
can do it is what this says and oh by
the way in the top five
professions teacher was number three
in the largest study of millionaires
ever done webster's with us
in the lobby on the debt-free stage to
do his
to tell us about being an everyday
millionaire so where do you live here in
nashville
talahoma talahama just down the road
just down the road yeah i love it i've
got a lake house right down by
yeah you should do yeah cool stuff so
what's your net worth webster
1.4 million good for you and give me a
little breakdown on that
retirement real estate so forth uh 250
000 is the house uh one million dollars
in retirement
and then two hundred thousand in
cash and a taxable investment account
good for you well done how old are you
64.
great but then you're supposed to say
webster you don't look like yourself you
don't look like you're 64 webster
you you look like you're now you look
like you're over here you look like
you're on the 32nd anniversary of your
32nd birthday
and so um what was your what's your
range of
income in your working life your best
year working your worst year working
well worst year was when i first started
in it
in uh 1977 making a whopping 400
a month okay 4 800
a year yeah yeah all right up to a high
of
180 180. good for you way to go
very cool so how much of the 1.4 million
did you inherit
two hundred thousand two hundred
thousand okay were you already a
millionaire when you got that
no so we got out of debt uh september
2005
and then my in-laws were at their final
stages of
life so we got some gifts from them
and then in 2008 my father-in-law passed
we inherited the house that was paid for
when we moved to tullahoma in august of
2008 we sold that paid for
house so we got a hundred and something
thousand dollars for the house
and then plus other gifts so from my
wife's side of the family we inherited
200 000 yeah 160 000 gotcha and then
when my parents passed uh we got about
another
additional 40 000 but by that time we
were millionaires okay but you almost
were
before that then yeah yeah okay all
right cool
so i i think it it boosted you but i
don't think we say you
are a millionaire because of inherited
money no no
but it it definitely gave you a leg up
it def it started the the
the first uh money into
the first ira came from the gifts from
the in-laws cool and you said your
career was i.t id
okay very good very good and uh what was
your gpa in college
uh i have no degree no degree zero
degree so
high school education yes okay good for
you
and you wandered into i.t in the 70s and
have been self-taught since
yes and or courses or whatever right
yeah a lot of certificates a couple
hundred certifications
yeah i bet mainly because um i
listened to you i've been listening to
you since um
november 1999 and so over the years
listen to you listen to others
especially when entre leadership
started yeah invest in yourself invest
in your skills
invest in your knowledge so when we
started
our so our we just had our 20-year
dave ramsey anniversary on march 25th
wow
so when we started i was making 36 000 a
year
okay and then over the four and a half
years that we paid off 197 thousand
dollars
uh our average income was 48 000. you
know there's an interesting insight
there and man i really appreciate the
history together and
i'm proud of that that i'm proud of you
guys with what you've done but here's
the interesting insight
this idea that okay you ever just run a
calculation you say if you invest this
much a month you'll be a millionaire
you know if you just invest if you
invest a hundred dollars a month from
age 25 to age 65 at 12
it's one point it's 1 million 176
thousand dollars okay so 100
a month you know so that that'll make
you think about where you spend 100
bucks right
so you just run that but here's the
thing it's never that simple
yeah because what's happened is is the
only way your money grew was you
continued to grow
yes as a person yes it was a holistic
thing going on here your spiritual walk
your relationship
uh your marriage all of those things
have to continue to grow and blossom as
well
or the little math formula quits working
doesn't it yeah i mean you've grown you
faster than this money grew even
yes is what it amounts to that's
beautiful i love that i have never seen
that before that's a very interesting
insight
so what advice do you have to a 25 year
old techie that's out there
can they become a millionaire yes they
can
um my advice to my
25 year old self would have been to have
listened to a very wise
woman that i knew at the time mrs
campbell
she was day before david's days
and her advice was always pay cash
never have debt always save
and always invest for your future and
always give
yes yeah and i wish my pig-headed
stubborn
obnoxious arrogant 20-something self
would have listened to her
yeah yeah this would be four million
[Laughter]
but you did okay webster you still got a
million four i'm so proud of you
congratulations sir you're living the
american dream thank you for taking time
very very nice brian is with us brian's
in raleigh north carolina brian what's
your net worth
uh 1.1 million days good for you give me
a little breakdown by category on that
how much retirement how much real estate
so forth
sure um i'm pretty uh real estate heavy
um
i got about eight eight fifty in real
estate and then
the remainder of that would be in
retirement 401k
okay so like 300 in that then all right
yeah about that yep good for you how old
are you
uh 27. wow look at you
dude well done so all this real estate
is paid for
oh yes sir wow all right so tell me
about this what was your best year i
mean in the four years you've been
working
what's the best [ __ ] five years your
seven years you've been working what's
your best year and worst year on income
um uh that's just a little over 200
um when i started out maybe
60. okay what do you do oh but i got
married in there too so
that adds a lot to it sure sure what do
you do for a living
i do i.t work i t good for you okay
there we go and this is theme right here
and uh how much of this money did you
inherit
uh none of it dave other than i mean i
got a
car when i turned at the average price
and the rest i've kind of worked on i've
done on my own
okay so did you get a four-year degree
or you work in certs
uh no i'd get a 40 i did get a four-year
degree from university yep
nit your science yeah computer science
no computer science yeah okay and what
was yours your gpa
uh about 3.9 good for you okay
all right so tell me the story because
this is you did a large amount in a
short period of time it looks like every
dollar you made went into paid for real
estate
yeah i've always liked real estate i was
really fortunate i work
all through even middle school i worked
all the summers
high school i worked after work after
school
i worked full time how old were you when
you bought your first piece of paid for
real estate
[Music]
um i bought uh i paid 50 down on my
first house when i was
21. wow way to go brian
man what a great story hey thank you for
sharing that
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
here on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you do not believe
that you can become a millionaire
that you can build wealth in america
today
there is a one thousand percent chance
that you will not build wealth
because you will not go do the things
that will cause you to build wealth
because you don't think they're going to
work you think the
game is rigged that you don't have a
chance to win
and you do have a chance to win so it is
my job to help you with your belief
and the way i do that is i use facts
not mythology not political
jargon not made up
things but detailed in-depth research
and talking to real people who have
become
wealthy during their lifetime one
definition of wealth is your net worth
it is the most used
definition of wealth to be a millionaire
what you own
minus what you owe so if you have at
least a million dollar net worth
and you're in that situation call me i
want to tell people what
everyday millionaires really look like
not what the media says
not what the left wing nuts say because
oh there are systemic problems with our
economy and the little men
can't get ahead you can't get ahead if
you're a woman you can't get ahead of
your
minority you can't get ahead if you're a
bald boomer
which would be me you can't get ahead
i'm so stupid guys i had to do it twice
i was a millionaire by the time i was 28
and i lost everything because i was
stupid
i borrowed up to my eyeballs i got rich
quick i built a house of cards and it
caved in
and i had to go do it again the second
time i did it i did it using the
principles i've taught you for the last
30 years
since going broke so i've done it twice
you can become a millionaire you can
build
wealth in america but see a farmer that
believes that if he plants
seeds that no crop will grow would never
plant seeds
that would be weird you have there
requires a level of faith the level of
belief that if i plant something i'm
going to grow something
if i save and sacrifice and stay out of
debt and actually be a grown-up
adults devise a plan and follow a
children do what feels good
then i can become a millionaire if you
do not believe that because
the systemic problems in the economy the
the deck is stacked and people say stuff
like i mean i grew up i heard people
saying
the little man can't get ahead
little man can't get ahead
you just work for the man
like eeyore is your freaking spirit
animal
you're never going to get ahead life's
rough
life's a life's a beach and then you die
you know oh my god you defeat us
fatalistic
idiot but i tell you what man you don't
have to be that way
you can choose to plant corn and
voila corn will grow if you save money
you will have some if you stay out of
debt and live on less than you make
you will eventually build wealth even if
you screw it up
you'll eventually get there kevin is our
next millionaire he's in mobile alabama
kevin what is your net worth sir
um we just crossed the threshold
1 million and forty two thousand dollars
love it
good for you give me a little breakdown
on that by category how much real estate
how much
retirement so forth all right we have
right at
this is probably a low ball number three
hundred thousand
is our home and it's paid for 680
000 and our investments 401k our rate
roth
rra and so forth and then 62
000 in our emergency fund money market
you know cash and other savings how old
are you
60 i just turned 63. good for you and
how much of this did you inherit
zero okay and what has been your working
income
your best year range and your worst year
uh well last year was mostly my income
my wife retired in january of last year
my income last year was right at 80.
probably 86 000. what did she make when
she was working
uh she probably making 60 plus okay she
had 150 000
household income as a high point yeah
yes sir and what was your low point
household income
uh probably you know i'm i'm guessing
uh you know 40 yeah okay
and uh what was your career well i'm
still working
uh i'm i'm i work in um
production inventory control logistics
warehouse management
basically logistics and warehouse
management gotcha and do you have a
four-year degree
no sir i do not two-year okay in what
uh industrial management yeah and then
you used it good
okay and what was your gpa in that
two-year
uh well well i was up there i was i did
it real late in life i graduated when i
was 50. so
after all my squander chances i probably
was right at 3.9 4.0
yeah good for you yeah because you
actually understood what you're supposed
to do yeah
yes sir yes sir good for you good for
you
so what do you tell a young man with a
high school education who's working in
logistics who can go get his two-year
associates later
and he's running his career can he still
be a millionaire
yes sir um you know
my story is kind of like yours i messed
up and
my 39 years old i lost everything long
story won't go there but so i had
the second half of my life i've done a
lot better bear bryant is quoted as
saying there's a lot of
blood sweat and guts between dreams and
success
another quote he says is don't give up
at halftime concentrate on winning the
second half and that's what i've done
second half of my life we buckle down
and concentrated and
here we are i've learned that heroes are
not
somebody you see on a movie screen
wearing capes
heroes sometimes wear hard hats and
steel toes but whining
yeah yes sir so good for you man good
for you i'm proud of you
well done well done thank you sir i
appreciate you calling and sharing your
story and congratulations on that
breaking that plane baby you did it
touchdown whoo yeah
jessica is with us jessica is in
sacramento
hi jessica what's your net worth hi dave
our
net worth is 1.2 million good for you
and give me a little breakdown by
category how much real estate and
retirement and so forth
so real estate you know we are in
california our house has paid off and
it's worth
just over six hundred thousand good
and then we have about 600 000 in roth
ira
mutual funds 401ks etc gotcha
and then about 50 000 cash good for you
well done how old are you i am 39
and my husband is 41. good for you young
millionaires good
how much of this 1.2 did you inherit
well we were fortunate we had
grandparents and great grandparents who
left us
a little bit of money so about 70 000 of
that was from them
50 000 though when i was 18 so there
wasn't much left
after very long okay so are you a
millionaire because of this inheritance
or it gave you a boost
it gave us a boost okay but you you
obviously didn't inherit a million
dollars okay
and your income range what was your best
in your household income
and your worst year household income
since you've been working
our worst year was when we both got off
of active duty
and it was about fifteen thousand and
our best year was this last year about
two hundred and forty three thousand
cool what do you do for a living i am a
registered nurse
and an air force reservist okay cool
and obviously you have a nursing degree
what was your gpa
from that degree was 4.0 4.0 you got it
get after it i love it
okay so a young nurse is out there
you're a young nurse but even younger
just coming out of school passing her
boards can she still become a
millionaire
absolutely what do you tell her to do
quick
uh choose your life partner wisely and
always move at the state of town
if you get love it move at the speed of
cash and avoid debt
like the plague you're listening to real
millionaires
who have built real wealth this is not
theory these are real people that are
doing it
you can too this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 13 11
dishonest money dwindles away
but whoever gathers money little by
little makes it grow
oh stephen king said what separates the
talented individual from the successful
one
is a lot of hard work well that's true
when people are hurting we want to make
it as easy as possible for them to get
the guidance and the resources they need
to get better
and that's why we do this every day we
help people
over the past year my team has been
really working hard building a brand new
website
that makes it so much easier for you to
find all the different
things you need the content the tools
the products the services
you need to win in any aspect of your
life not just money but everything
and guess what it launches this week
it's called ramseysolutions.com no
kidding
so instead of daveramsey.com we are now
ramsey solutions.com
it's slick it's your one-stop shop for
everything ramsay you'll find all our
ramsey personalities there
including rachel ken anthony christie dr
john and of course me
all in one spot and all the things
having to do with us with no wild goose
chase
so just go to ramseysolutions.com check
it out surf around a little bit
see what's happening at the new site
it's beautiful and it's easy to find
stuff
uh the other one had been built like a
country house we just kept adding rooms
over the years and
the architecture was just a wee bit
unstable to say the least
so we're so excited about how strong and
powerful and easy this new one is
just for you guys so well done this
is a millionaire theme hour as we talk
to real millionaires people with a
million dollar net worth more
greater to get from them how they've
lived how they did that to convince you
that you too can do this ryan is in
indianapolis ryan what is your net worth
uh 1.1 1.1 million give me a little
breakdown on that
uh mix between everything 200
farmland 350 retirement 450
equity in the house 100 000 in
investments and
restless miscellaneous cars toys
good for you how old are you 35 and my
wife's 41.
wow young millionaires today lots of
them uh how much of this did you inherit
zero okay and what was your best
household income
working year and your worst household
income working year um
zero and uh we're about 200 now
cool what do y'all do for a living uh i
expedite freight my wife works she's an
orthopedic
surgical manager okay all right cool
and you have a four-year degree
no no degree uh my wife has a bachelor's
so you got a high school and she's got a
bachelor's
correct okay cool cool so how do you
become a millionaire at 35 what's the
secret
um uh there is no secret you just gotta
work hard and
uh save um i i think that as long as
you're
having fun working on sacrificing and
pretending like it's 1800s you don't
ever need borrow money
and just let it live below your means
before we had kids there was spence
where i'd work 16 to 20 hour days and we
were
living in a rented trailer and
we did that to build a solid foundation
and to save
uh to build our house okay
and and you've got a paid for farm and a
house with a bunch of equity in it
a bunch of money in retirement all at 35
years old
yes sir yeah way to go man that house we
just saw a picture of it pop up on
youtube it's beautiful
that's a good looking house man well
done i love it congratulations i'm proud
of you guys
okay so today all of the net worths were
slightly over a million one point three
one point four one point one one
one point two one point one there are no
ten million dollars calling it today no
five million or even two million calling
it today
but the ages were unusually young today
37
27 41 35
and 64 and 63. uh by the way the
statistical average of a millionaire in
america today is 52.
on average it took them 17 years to get
there from the time they got their crap
together and started working on it
okay because we all a lot of people go
through the you know the blue period
where they just do stupid stuff like i
lost everything in my 20s i just start
over right
and so then 17 years later quicker than
17 i
had my next million back they always say
the second millions easier
you know it is you know why it is
because you've done it and you know you
can do it when you've never done it
before you don't know
you can do it you think you can do it
you see other people do it you think
this is going to work you can do the
math you can do the projections
but once you've lived in it and done it
you felt it you walked in it you go oh
yeah i can do that
and then you go i need you know i think
i need to work on 10 million and then i
need to work on 30 million and then you
need to you know you just
once you've done it you know you what's
the next
thing you're going to do what's the next
process
and so these guys did it
and by the way out of them uh one of
them inherited 200 one of them inherited
70.
both of them said those were booster
seats they were not the reason they
became a millionaire but it did help
and obviously if you get 100 or 200 000
or something like that it does help you
become a millionaire but let me tell you
what the mythology is
if you do take a mic and go down the
street the man on the street interviews
right you say
tell me about wealthy people well they
inherited their wealth
and see if you believe that and you
don't have a rich uncle that means
you're screwed
so why when why go out there and save
why go out there and try to be
successful because the only way to be
wealthy is inherit your money
the game is rigged and if you don't
happen to win the dna lottery in a
wealthy family
you're not going to get there that's
what that's the problem with that
mythology
is it destroys hope
and the bible says hope deferred makes
the heart sick
here's another one wealthy people are
all crooks that's how they got their
money
well i didn't talk to any crooks today i
talked to a construction manager a
couple i.t guys a logistics guy
a a nurse and a and a
and a guy who's a freight distributor
i didn't talk to any crooks
there were no no no movies gonna be made
about these people stealing
them bernie madoff was not on the show
today
so this idea that wealthy people are all
crooks is insulting to those of us
that saved and worked our butts off
and didn't steal a dime and provided
service to the marketplace
pisses us off when you say that quit
saying it it's wrong
it's a lie well all wealthy people are
famous people
they're entertainers they're rock stars
country music stars
they play professional sports
the statistically less than one percent
of america's millionaires
are recognizable names due to
them being in the spotlight they're not
professional athletes
statistically less than one percent are
actors
entertainers professional athletes
and i've worked with the nfl we've
worked with the nhl
we've even worked with the nba a couple
of times
and let me tell you what nfl stands for
not for long
their average career length is 3.7 years
the number of guys that become
millionaires playing football
is very low and a lot of them as we all
know
screw that up oh in order to be a
millionaire and be wealthy you have to
be inordinately
brilliant another lie
gpas today were all in the threes except
one 4.0
no one had six phds
no one had them all with 4.00 no one
invented a a a
a chemistry formula that's going to get
them the nobel peace prize
these are working people that lived on
less than they make
doing it nursing
logistics and construction management
now let me just tell you too i will tell
you that the average millionaire
is above a 2.5 gpa
because they applied themselves to their
studies they had a level of discipline
by the way if you go to class most of
the time you get a 2.5
if you just go to class i mean really
and quit playing beer pong i mean just
go to class and you'll get a 2.5
but most of us that are wealthy are not
4.2
my gpa was 2.97 in college
yes i'm pissed off about the three one
hundredths of a point i missed it by
three one hundredths of a point so
but you know what hadn't held me back at
all i've done okay
the point of this everyday millionaire
theme hour is you can do it
and you should do it and i fully expect
you to do it and i want to hear from you
on this hour
when you do it i want to celebrate you
you're america's heroes
that puts this hour of the dave ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you